[Music]
hey Mark what you doing
I think we need to do mark
[Music]
oh hi mark oh hi mark what are we doing
today well today we're gonna be baking
it already
I know give him a try hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to the
bacon simulator 2014 and often requested
game by you guys and I think this might
be a prank pulled on me but then again
baking is a very serious business many
people have lost their lives in tragic
baking accidents anyway arrow keys to
move WASD one control left hand right
hand move character there seems to be a
problem in the hand controls well now
you're gonna really point it out because
you guys might be able to notice it for
yourself if your observational skills
are sharp anyway so let's get into it
because we're gonna bake up a storm over
here this was made in 48 hours by the
way and Ludum dare game gym oh that's
how that is that that do so is a cat do
I hear a damn cat how do I move where's
my hands ok then I've lost my hands I
seem to be struggling a little bit here
so apparently did not move like a maroon
you need to actually have a gamepad and
not just the mouse and stick because
there was a bit of a problem if all the
fingers were controlled by left shift
although I know with my gaming skills I
would have been able to do it anyway oh
I have horribly horrific ly deformed
hands what happened to my fingers why
are they just nubs ok I did not read the
instructions but I know they're over
here hello
give me a moment I need to educate
myself all right we're ready to go I got
it I got it okay
add all ingredients to bowl but bolt
without oh that's what you was you
weren't a cat you were gay oh you mess
with me oven I don't have any paces for
you I need to build a damn cake or bake
one rather oh this is gonna be good I
got ya that is creepy as hell but I'm
gonna get you up because that's how I
roll baby
that's oh goodness gravy boy this is no
[Music]
come here I shall cast a spell of
sleeping on you that's the wrong hand
oh no the flowers trying to run away and
escape you can't escape this fate it's
far too horrible for you to even
consider running away from hope hope oh
god this is the most oh it's not good
enough do I actually need to pour it and
how do I do that yeah okay we're over
that way
pour it in I'm baking like a boss
someone tell Jack I'm baking like he is
do wow I put okay that was too much [ __ ]
no no too much it's not gonna be a good
one oh that doesn't seem right
okey-dokey then I'm just gonna pick that
up okay I'll move yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah we're on a roll here
we're actually doing some sort of good
but all they did they bleep dead come
here you
I gotta that's the entire ball but I
just wanted a little bit of you
yeni oh so gently on the baking master
even though I put almost eight times as
much flowers you actually need but
normal human being I'm not so ah
let it go let it go there we go okay
bye-bye mr. Sugarman I'm gonna go on an
adventure with my weird hand somehow we
got a delicately take one of these eggs
and we got to crack it open that
shouldn't be too hard and I shouldn't be
too hard I mean I'm gonna die over and
over again until I get oh I got one oh
my god
Hey oh I'm shocked that I myself even
got that now I'm just gonna gently maybe
I just need to drop it in there
[Applause]
caressing that's one too many
I just have one right because if I have
more than one there we go I'm much
happier now and by much happier I mean
what the hell am I doing with my life ha
ha who cares if the eggshells are in
there they add more texture more flavor
now we just need the but tear don't tell
me I'm gonna fail this just because I
have way too much flour just because
they get artistically creative doesn't
mean that you need to judge me
Todd's just waiting yeah it's a good
stuff that's how you know the butter is
good you really get in there with your
weirdo fingers this is freaking anyone
else up okay pick it up go over there
walk like a normal human being
I actually Octodad I might actually be
Octodad right now let go of it ha ha we
did it right we did it
okay so now I need to pick up the bowl
but I should probably do that with both
hands such that I do not wreck
everything that I've worked for switch
okay
Coleco raise you raise you up and then I
put oh god oh god okay that was the C
exhales no big deal switch hands let go
ha ha ha have I got you do I have you Oh
on the past come on how do I get yes
oh I'm not high enough okay that's
tricky that's normal okay raise you up
raise you up perfectly normal way I hope
no one walks into this kitchen sees the
monstrosity that I am this doesn't burn
me at all on the past yes come on screw
you that's a perfect cake okay so
apparently that first cake sucks so I'm
gonna do this right now I'm gonna do it
perfect to not have any eggshells in it
because that apparently sucks ass oh
praise he be sugar I'm gonna grab you
and then I'm gonna pour you in a bowl
are you happy with that
better be just about to have it anyway
now we apply our skills to gently gently
gently add the sugar into the bowl not
pouring as it seems
come on don't tell me I have the wrong
way don't freak out on me I got ya okay
we're gonna raise you up this is
perfectly normal to have it clipping
through my hand like this that's how I
lost some fingers back in Nam
oh come on it could be there my hand was
my palm stopping it from going through
your stupid and I hate you reset drop it
Oh dad so you want to drop it oh that's
fantastic for you and spill it there we
go oh this is gonna take forever could I
in any way speed this up oh god I sped
it up Wow
whoa whoo hee whoo oh wait whoa why are
you going in fits and burst now oh now
be gentle with it caress the sugar a
little more Oh Oh perfect arrow top
score for me and drop it perfect exactly
what I wanted I'm gonna be able to get
that out when I sugar sugar all the Bowl
your whatever screw it oh wait I'm
supposed to get another egg I'm dumb
well let's take care of this first
Oh do that he's gonna be much more
difficult oh oh it's like being a
gasoline pump so badly let it go let it
go just make us cake and go to hell oh
yeah yeah that's the thing appear too
right there let me go ahead and pick
those shells out because I'm a gentleman
like that that's not what I wanted I
don't got anything it was just a
sleight-of-hand trick I fooled you again
didn't I okay three times the fools on
you well [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah perfect sheikha sugar sugar
yes yes yes come on ow oh oh I'm the
best I'm officially the best oh I'm so
happy with myself
Oh Connor there oh let me just do this
before I lose in lose ole game cuz I've
been playing this for way too long
and the crowd goes moderately impressed
oh oh raise it raise it oh god no no
even think about it
if the bugger still in there am i
slipping enough for everybody
don't the white you put it down no oh
god no your thumb into it - yeah yeah
now we're gonna move forward okay not
screwing it up yet okay so switching
this one okay not have them both right
yeah yeah yeah no the butter the butter
escape what the butter stop eh yeah no
you are sassy sue I don't like you but
if you could just be normal for just a
little longer I'll be able to get this
done and over with
let me just grab the butter oh so
daintily no like a gentleman don't have
the butter it's just courting it first
through my hand okay the butter is just
gonna set the butter is actually already
in there and I actually don't need to
worry about it at all apparently is it
how are neither of you holding on to it
how I'm about to lose my goddamn mind I
got a perfect cake here waiting for me
oh you sassy no grab on raise up hold
still what you you shut up no I just
needed the one I'm such an idiot I've
left the butter behind now let's do that
forever
open up you [ __ ] sorry cultures angry
what the Frick can still get it would it
go it evaporated into the floor oh my
perfect cake I have to do this again
fantastic I've been playing this game
for 25 minutes yo and I'm just gonna put
this hand away because it's a danger to
society at this point I just need to do
this on my own with good ol lefty over
here because that's my favourite hand
yeah yeah that's the stuff oh yeah nice
even pour on that easily the first time
then I got better at the game it's fine
just [ __ ] ass I'm going to kill I'm
going to kill with this cake I'm going
to kill it may not be alive sadly the
stupidity is don't you spaz out you
douche okay I got myself sugar hey okay
did not press that hand
why is your thumb out is that a thumbs
up are you a Roman Emperor about to
screw me over
don't screw me over hand saw what you
did there
backwards reversed spore Oh everybody
knows best strategy for faking simulator
come on it's such a donker I don't even
know what a dunker is but you're that is
this just me or does this look like a
paranoids right now
well then this is gonna be very painful
for you Oh screw you
oh hey whoa hey whoa well this is normal
I got the ball here and I took care of
my egg prom at the same time well good
thing I got a firm grip on that there
Bowl that's normal
can I still win the game somehow no idea
something has gone horribly awry let me
just get that that might my wrist is
very slender there am i the slender man
was I baking a cake for myself the whole
time oh you're so thoughtful douche go
to hell what even is this and what way
is this normal get it in there how did
this happen I'm gonna do this god damn
it I'm gonna do God come here and you're
gonna well [ __ ] I didn't move you just
suddenly decided to spurt out everywhere
god I hate it when that happens
I'm the worst okay okay we're good we're
shut off we're cut off
you've had enough flour for one day you
stay over there flower you've been a bad
boy and I don't take kindly to you I'm
gonna get this arm out of here because
it's getting in my way
I'm just gonna get my left arms going
down southward towards my crotch but
that's okay he's just hello hi Muir
hello well that's new
[Music]
love Bob Bob I'm weird the buttery treat
that can't be beat necessity in all-boy
canned goods not baking goods but waking
goods gently like an elegant butterfly
and the wood of okey then you do your
thing over there I'm gonna bake a cake
all the past can't get rid of those okay
all good wait a minute that's not it no
three eggs what did you pick up that egg
you're such an idiot
this gives me a bad score it's not even
that it's not even on it fell through
the floor it's not even there whatever
you know what at this point I just want
to be done cooking I want to go home let
my life be free be free okay goodbye
wait a minute
good boy good boy by the power of Satan
I command thee to be unbelievably
delicious and feed all the starving
people ever me - no not you Thumb you're
weird
[Music]
than I thought it would this is the way
I'm happy that I did it numbers thank
you all so much for not to include the
entities and as always you're turning
suddenly you're murdering the entire
city that guy ran under your tires
everyone